bonsoir monsieur l'abbé 50 ans bilan
évidemment positif et en même temps
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas lassé de vous
répéter de de pousser des coups de
gueule pour dire qu'il faut faire
changer ce monde
non là c'est non je suis vieux
ça oui mais moralement
là c'est de me battre cela non
voyez-vous pour ça que sur spectateurs
qui regardent ils peuvent être dans
l'admiration dire c'est beaucoup c'est
une réussite 50 ans ça aurait pu se
casser la figure
tous les jours bon étant donné qu'il n'y
a aucun triage parmi les compagnons qui
arrive on lui demande harry un renouveau
tu as faim tu veux déjà dès que dormir
non et puis on nous expliquera après on
dira comme on vit souvent celui qui
arrive ne le sait pas et il le découvre
et quelquefois il ne reste pas il
reprend la route
mais d'autres fois il reste il lui reste
jusqu'à son dernier soupir
pour ceux qui à voir de l'extérieur on
peut le dire c'est merveilleux mais
quand on est dedans on ne voit que ce
qui est parfait
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas pu faire que c
hacun n'est pas peu dire oui vient on
attendait parce que il me faudrait avoir
trouvé une autre ville un terrain un
responsable et c'est un peu comme un bon
docteur un bon docteur il gèle matin
fred ayant que tous les coups de
sonnettes battra pour lui dire j'ai mal
j'ai mal
alors s'il avait vous faites allusion à
votre âge qu'est ce que vous allez
transmettre qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
transmettre
comment vous voyez la poursuite de notre
action lorsque vous ne serez plus de ce
monde
c'est simple tout société le monde la
terre entière
maintenant que nous entrons dans une
époque d'humanité planétaire toute
société est là à faire le choix entre
deux principes fondamentaux ou bien le
service premier d'effort ou bien servi
ce mois bien les plus petits des plus
faibles
dans une famille la société la plus
élémentaire
c'est une famille alors si dans une
famille parce que les aider le papa et
la maman sont des costauds on entre on
sait en tout cas que les portes sans
faire aucune attention
un nouveau-né un malade un vieillard
c'est l'enfer il n'y a plus de société
la famille est perdu or nos sociétés
sont toutes malades de souvent
d'ailleurs
inconsciemment il y a des fripouilles
qui en sont très conscients qu'ils en
tirent leurs profits mais pour le plus
grand nombre c'est des braves gens qui
ne sont pas assez témoin de détresse qui
appellerait des actions nouvelles
mais pas ce que je veux quand on devient
vieux on a comme une voix intérieure qui
dit avant ton dos les jeans que tu sais
bien ce que le jeu jeudi
quand on pose une question de secondes
ce que je sais c'est que la vie c'est à
peu de temps 86 ans tient peu par
rapport au million de centaines de
millions d'années du temps c'est un peu
de temps donnée à des libertés ou si tu
veux apprendre à aimer c'est ça la règle
de vie d'une société viable heureuse si
devant le petit tout le monde va
s'arranger pour le servir et lui
permettre de devenir tout ce qu'il est
capable de devenir alors c'est une vraie
société
c'est une vraie famille est ce que je
dis quand je peux me rendre encore dans
les communautés il y en a 100 6 jan 10 à
travers lui affronte actuellement et tôt
350 quelque chose comme ça entre 32 pays
où 36 pays oui craquer le répète
continuellement c'est cela servir
premier le plus faible servir premier le
plus souffrant et
mais je l'avais est ce que est ce que
vous êtes gêné par le fait d'être
sanctifié de votre vivant vous êtes le
français le plus apprécié par la france
est ce que est ce que vous êtes gênés ou
est ce que vous dites au fond c'est une
force supplémentaire
geoffrey coupable ne l'utilisé pas comme
une force pour que le faible reçoive le
coup de main dont il a besoin et que la
société s'organise c'est une porte
j'en suis très conscient et je veux
l'utiliser au maximum cette forme mais
vous êtes quand même un incorrigible
optimiste vous titrez votre livre
fraternité chez fayard vous croyez qu'on
peut encore faire un monde fraternel
quand on entend parler des guerres des
affrontements la violence économique
savez malraux cette parole célèbre le
21ème siècle sera religieux ou ne sera
pas je termine ce livre en disant bien
au delà de simplement qu'affective
religieuse le monde sera fraternelle ou
ne sera pas et le fondement d'une foi
religieuse donnera force à cette
fraternité
mais si on ne veut pas en fait fait en
sur vos enfants avant qu'il sait pas
très longtemps
ils y seront contraints quand ça ne
serait ce par la crainte par la peur
devant les colères qui menace sur le
plan national ou sur le plan
international les partage ce livre n'est
que ça montrant les chemins de partage
auquel désormais on ne peut pas échapper
je vous remercie monsieur l'abbé d'être
venu nous nous dire votre témoignage ce
soin et puis nous allons achever ce
journal